hi it's me again did you realize that
the biggest benefit of internment of
fasting has nothing to do with weight
loss okay so the biggest benefit has to
do with this new concept called etapa G
I don't know if you've heard about
before but if you haven't you're going
to hear about it but it's incredible
actually etapa G is the condition or
state whereby the cells are recycling
damaged cell parts okay so it's a
recycling it's taking out the trash it
clears all the trash out of the cell
it's also getting rid of pathogenic
microbes okay so basically anything like
mold fungus bacteria virus sitting in
the cell and anything that's damaged not
working so each cell has a little
garbage disposal called the lysosome
composed of enzymes to break down these
parts into small little particles which
are then sent to the liver to be used
either as energy or recycling into new
tissue okay
etapa G was discovered by a Japanese
scientist in 2016 so just think about
the magnitude if you were to able to
extract pathogenic microbes damaged
things out of your cell think what's
going to happen to your brain cognitive
effects anti-aging for your skin
longevity immune system it's incredible
so the thing that stimulates this the
most is fasting and in a minute fasting
okay that's number one so if you're not
fasting or doing intermittent fasting
you need to start that immediately okay
I put a link down below more information
on that but there's some other things
that will also increase it to some
degree not near as much as intermittent
fasting but olive oil aerobic exercise
that would be like low intensity
exercise walking yoga things like that
then we have sulfur fain which is
basically a phytonutrient category with
all the cruciferous type vegetables okay
interesting we always come back to the
cruciferous vitamin d3 will increase it
b3 vitamin b3 will also do it the
phytonutrients in coffee but again if
you're going to do coffee just do a
small amount green tea coconut and
there's many more things on the list so
this then makes sense because if you
take a look at someone who's eating
frequently they're raising insulin over
a period of time they become insulin
resistant pre-diabetic become a diabetic
I mean look what happens to the
cognitive function look what happens to
the cells they age fast they get
inflammation their poor immune system so
I put a little link down below to get
more data in a minute fasting all right
thanks for watching hey if you haven't
already subscribed press this little
button down below okay thanks